la realidad es es el fuego sería una
necesidad del problema es que no es
solamente un problema de carácter
militar sino que también involucra la
posible salida diplomática durante más
de tres décadas el proceso de paz no va
a aumentar porque el gobierno al medio
no tenía ningún incentivo para sentarse
a negociar esto es tenían los
territorios y por lo tanto no había
ningún incentivo para que se sentaran a
negociar y a la vez el proceso de paz
hizo que azerbaiyán se sintiera
demasiado frustrado con este no avance
de las negociaciones es por eso que la
situación militar hoy en día complejiza
todo porque porque ahora armenia siente
la necesidad de sentarse a negociar
mientras que azerbaiyán ha perdido el
incentivo para hacerlo creo que ahí será
en los próximos días deberemos ver como
las grandes potencias los miembros del
grupo de minsk que son la instancia
negociadora se ponen a brindarle tanto a
armenia como azerbaiyán una posible
salida diplomática